rules that speak to ron peck he is a
retired teacher
he lost his dad during lockdown early
this year hello to you ron thank you for
joining us um tell us about it okay
thank you thank you
morning
tell me about your dad
oh um he was a retired infantryman um
who saw active service with the
middlesex regiment
very proud englishman and
he rang me that's him and he rang me
last year to tell me that his uh cancer
and his heart condition meant that it
would probably be his last christmas now
unfortunately we
live about 110 miles away so we
drove and met in the rain on the front
door
and exchanged
um gifts
and to make things a little bit worse my
mum has uh late stage dementia so she
had no idea what was going on
and that was the last time i saw him
unsadly he passed away in
march
what was his name
his name was ron two it's that tradition
of the sixties of calling your children
the same name
[Music]
um when you look back at
last christmas seeing him uh in the rain
on on the doorstep
um and then you hear what was happening
at more or less the same time uh
allegedly in downing street how do you
feel well it's it's very difficult to
put into words first of all i know that
tens of thousands of people had the same
experience i don't think i'm special at
all
but um i feel devastated and you know
really upset and and really can't really
rate it that well it's it's it's just
appalling and i don't think
people in power really understand what
it's like for the people who kept all
the rules
um the prime minister has consistently
said as as
later goes yesterday actually yesterday
afternoon he was saying that there
wasn't a party and no rules were broken
do we have to accept what he said at
face value
well i'm afraid i don't and um it's
pretty obvious if if you follow the
story that there's a plenty of evidence
and and i'm
i'm afraid it seems to be a bit of a
pattern where where lies just globally
given
and um and it's just the public that
suffer it it makes me very very angry
is it ron for you that the rules were
allegedly broken or is it
the way in the video that we saw last
night that people thought it was quite
funny to try to
come up with things that they um
stories that they could use to cover up
what might have happened
i think it's both okay i think that you
know
most people sat and and see your
coverage of the news and see that that
it's pretty obvious that there's one
rule for them and a different rule for
everybody else but yesterday the the
footage that emerged of his pres his
press secretary was just
uh appalling too i mean i i should
imagine i'm a bit like many other people
i've not managed to sleep for four or
five days this is just such an appalling
occurrence the way that they have
contempt for the electorate
so just just tell me a bit more about
that ron if you would you say that
you've not been able
to sleep um that's because of the
injustice or or what is it what's
stopping you from basically and and and
the the lies and the state that the
country is in
um because of this and obviously it as i
say i don't think it's not about me but
it's brought back all the memories of uh
dad and mum in the rain in the garden
and and just
people
laughing at us
tell us a good memory about your dad
oh well he was very hard-working
extremely hard-working man and um
he gave us a
love of music and sports
and uh
you know and and we we buried him early
april or so he cremated him and and we
could only have half a dozen people
there
and it it just
you know it's all all part of the same
thing but he was a great man and i think
everyone would say that
handsome devil as well wasn't he
he certainly was he certainly was that
was often commented um
and that's a great picture that uh he
was in a documentary um which that is
from about national service i think was
1958 and that's often shown that clip
and and uh you can see why he was picked
i certainly can handsome devil as i said
um just before i let you go we know that
downing street watch our program um
every morning what do you want to say
i don't think unlike many people i've
got nothing left to say to them
if they had any sense of decency
they would do the decent thing but they
haven't done the decent thing at any
point and that makes me very sad and
angry
and as far as the prime minister is
concerned what would be the decent thing
as far as your concern would it be to
say he's sorry
absolutely not i've seen a lot of um
comment and even comment from the leader
of the opposition that we need demanding
apology
i think most people in the electorate
demand a lot more than an apology it's
it's just very very bad
okay uh ron i'm sorry you had to relive
what happened earlier this year but
thank you for taking the time look after
yourself
like your
thank you